good morning believe nation I hope you
guys are doing well welcome to gratitude
gratitude journal live stream number or
what are we 27 it's going to be back
it's good to have you on board we do
this every day to create happier
healthier more grateful entrepreneurs
who can go out and crush on their goals
and change the world i I'm going to
share three things that I group before I
want you guys in a chat share three
things you're great before today for
those of you watching later on the
replay leave it down in the comments
below three things you were grateful for
you could join me every day at nine a.m.
Eastern to do this with you quickly ah
again I sort of this has something like
my team and it sort of paying off big
dividends and I thought you know what
let's bring this to believe nation you
guys can benefit from it too the key is
consistency it's happening regularly
it's every day it's every every weekend
honey and Eastern if you're not doing
with me do it on your own just do it
once a week once a month is not enough
and that you feel it and that you just
ask yourself why you're grateful for
don't just list stuff off you want to
get the benefits of it you want to be
happier of all the surveys that are out
there but why people are happy gratitude
is always always always on that list so
to get the benefit you have to feel it
so I'm at first I'm going to share three
things I'm grateful for and give you
guys some shoutouts uh number one is
easy i finished my audio book yesterday
i was super jazzed and you guys helped
me a lot i love yesterday's gratitude
stream um I mean I love all of them but
i really love yesterday's i love xenos
one about the clouds adding diversity to
the skyline and someone else was
grateful for obstacles because it allows
your creative solutions I don't know man
that's turning up I love this stuff you
guys are killing it um I finished outer
but yesterday it was supposed to take me
three days we did in two and we were
sitting there at the end of the day at
five o'clock and we had ten pages left
which will take about 25 minutes 20
minutes to do and said you wanted you
want to keep doing I do you want to
finish it yeah I want to finish it of
course on this shift I don't want to
take breaks let's finish
this and one of my producers are
produced in Toronto producer in LA and
the producer in Toronto had this
infection he fell off his bike in like
bit his mouth and had this big infection
going on and like you know what man it's
up to you you're you're struggling
through this I know it's been a long day
for you you let me know I'm good either
way I'll come back next week if you want
like no no no let's get it done let's
get it done a feeling it's all super
good one for the team and finishing the
book um so much fire I've recorded the
video afterwards just pure fired
excitement so I'm really excited they
see that that come out uh number 2 i'm
great for open mindedness i'm going for
that i'm open minded and a lot of you
guys are there was a comment this
morning on we did enter press 0 on
justin bieber and it was love what you
do and it was a good video and somebody
left a comment saying something like if
you need to take advice from just a
justin bieber you're in rough shape so i
wrote back to say that if you're so
close minded that you can't learn from
justin bieber you're in rough shape the
fact that people are not able to learn
from people who had more success than
them you may not like a lot about justin
bieber you can still learn from him it
still take things that have made him
successful and apply it to your life in
your business so just open mindedness
I'm grateful for open-mindedness in
general um it just blows my mind blows
my mind how some people think and number
3 i'm capable for my beard i'm likely
losing it tonight my beer goes with my
oh I have my blue jays had on we lost
last night one more game come on let's
go tonight um yeah so as my hair gets
long my beer gets long that's half
that's how I roll and so I'm probably in
the haircut tonight so the beard is off
Nina's not a fan so anyway I'm grateful
for my beard while it lasts and that I
can grow back all right that's what I
got we have six minutes I'm going to go
through what you guys have so leave it
in the live chat we did some shoutouts
what do we got what do we got we got no
bills started us off he's always the
first one now these days what do you
give for today
nation thank you for getting us up Zino
said while you're early I love it Zeno
is grateful for the recovery of my left
calf I had a sort of crack for a couple
weeks but it feels great now I love that
man number two music for its ability to
set and change my mood a hundred percent
I need to start the day with music every
day before doing this I'm listening to
music it just it just resets it just
gets you in the right mindset number
three my eyes this time for not allowing
me to see but they're my favorite
physical feature we got two body parts
of the Daisy no calf and I I love it
what else Zeno how was it yesterday I
mean the audiobook thing I could ask
about your voice but I can still hear it
in 12 minutes voice is okay it's not a
hundred percent but it's okay and we did
we did we did good gri is thankful for
abundant directed focused energy for my
computer which helps me create
contribute and be here with the leave
nation I love that for my unique blend
of talents and passions and that helped
make me me that's himself love there I
love that cold glass morning everyone
morning cold what's up what's up kelbee
and good morning and welcome back
Melissa good morning believe community
welcome Melissa colt I'm grateful for
this experience the ups and the downs
I'm so grateful that I can experience as
feast and famine instead of just always
being somewhere in the middle hashtag
entrepreneur life interesting Caleb and
I'm grateful for one obtaining the
position for USMLE step one tutor at my
university congrats to for pizza hut
stuffed crust pepperoni lover's pizza I
love that man you make me hungry now
three presidents beers Presidente beers
but no Presidente beers are enough to
check that it relaxing sleep station
he's in a glad the calf yield rishi
couple of everyone welcome back Rishi
what else what else what else ray hello
guys welcome ray but we got Roberto
morning to have a roberto blake welcome
roberto another fellow youtube creator
go check out his awesome content and
he's in the book to Roberto
man I was channeling you yesterday in
the video sorry in the audio recording
it was awesome breathe fitness TV just
popping to say just popping in to say hi
everyone welcome breathe fitness TV
Melissa I'm grateful for flower in my
garden and the sunny day today I love
that Tim gratitude Tuesday I love that
what else we got what else we got
relaxing sleep station I'm grateful that
Tia's dad is going to get the police
check even though it's not easy for him
don't know what that's all about but it
sounds deep so I'm super I'm super happy
for you what else relaxing sleep station
i'm grateful that I get to hear the
sounds of children playing it's a good
sound I like it and I'm grateful for
clean minded meditation I had this
morning be very cool you guys meditate
I've been on and off for meditation
again I can't I can't I haven't felt the
benefits of meditation as much of
gratitude anyway we'll see Kelly hey
everyone ever i'm sorry ahead of time
but i'm grateful for the cleveland
indians kicking butt Kelly Kelly this is
not the place to talk about the
Cleveland Indians hashtag home also
grateful for hot Cleveland weather and
protein shakes okay we'll go with
weather and protein shakes not happy
Kelly Melissa I'm given for t25 exercise
keep in shape and I can eat whatever I
want I love that what else Joe good
morning everyone I missed you guys we
missed you Joe welcome back tan my
computer keeps me fresh weapons talking
and I'm not catching it I'm sorry here
are the rest of you guys catching it
hope you're catching it coach Billy
Cooper I'm grateful for cheerios I love
that I love that what else what else
what else what else do we got what we
got Melissa I'm grateful for success
principal jack canfield in Spanish I
love that next we're gonna have to do
your one word in Spanish will have Rishi
Cup TV read it out zohair 1452 can
anyone tell me how to meditate
it's a good question maybe I've been
doing it wrong too I don't know marking
the cars in the house mark drinker he is
I missed it oh there it is good morning
y'all welcome mark thank you tan for
that making sure that i gave this shout
out there and the comments just exploded
what do we got we got what do we got
what do we got give me some more sabita
hello everyone I'm shweta all right
welcome aboard ie from much who's
grateful for flexibility I love that
sabrine I'm grateful that I finally got
myself together and started a healthy
diet I love that beautiful for my
positive mindset today and finally
grateful for my money looking good Casey
first-time listener welcome casey three
before you this morning thank you for
reminding me about the nonverbal
communication in the field glad I could
help cut DDI too i hope i pronounced
that ok wiffle for people who sincerely
love me for who I really am and tim is
grateful for the crisp fall weather in
Nebraska it's super hot in cleveland
crisp fall weather in Nebraska I love it
guys thank you so much for joining me
it's nine ten we're going to hop over to
twitch do some league of legends live
stream while answering business
questions with g rise and rishi cup TV
if this is the last time i see they'll
have an amazing day i hope you go and
crush your goals continue to believe or
whatever your one where it is and I'll
see you soon